(logo whooshes)
(soft delightful music)
- I am Daniela Rus and I'm
here with my PhD student,
Johnson Wang and my postdoc Byungchul Kim
and together we are building
towards the future of robot
design and manufacturing,
specifically we're building
a system called DiffuseBot,
the system combines the
best of generative AI
with the best of physics-based simulation
to create a generative AI
approach for mechanisms
that can operate in the physical world.
- This is an example of
a robot that's generated
by DiffuseBot and its goal
is to try to move that box,
so it generate motion
like this rolling motion
to try to move the box,
it kind of combine the generative power
with physical utility.
I first tried to build
a physical simulation
that's try to provide, kind
of like a learning signal,
for the generative models to
do the task in the simulation
and afterwards we can actually fabricate
as we using 3D carbon printer.
So think about now you
wanna customize robots
for a certain physical task,
how long will you spend you
to actually make the robot?
- [Byungchul] Maybe it requires two weeks
to one month, maybe?
- [Johnson] It took
roughly, probably 30 seconds
to specify the high level specification
and then it took roughly like
6 to 12 hour of computer time
to actually optimize the robot
and then I hand the design to Byungchul.
- It requires four hours of 3D printing
and after that I need about
30 minutes to one hour
to post-process the printer.
- So the entire pipeline
only takes like one hour
of human time and rest of the hours
we kind of outsource that to computer
and this is the coolest
thing of DiffuseBot.
Like the previous robot
where it try to move the box
from left to right, this robot,
we specify the high level
objective as a picking up object,
the gripper that's automatically generated
by DiffuseBot, using
diffusion generative AI,
it can learn to know
to generate this kind of
parallel gripper-like shape
and that can allow it to actually achieve
the physical utility,
which is clamp the object
and then pick it up.
We use the exact same pipeline,
the only difference is,
basically we specify
different high level objective,
so basically we still have
this kind of physical
assimilation in the computer
and then it'll automatically
optimize the robot
to this specific shape.
The diffusion process actually
look like this, for example,
it start from kind of like a random noise
and then it gradually converge
to a gripper-like shape
as we see in here and also
in the physical robots.
The most limitations
happens in same to real gap,
because of the material we are using,
the stiffness is pretty large,
so it requires a large force
to actually bend the griper
and then generate desired
motion to pick up the objects.
- [Byungchul] We have to
think about the stiffness
of the robot, so I have
to redesign the robot body
to make it softer.
- There's still some kind of gap
between the actual material
we use in the physical world
and the simulation we build.
So this kind of gap is kind of troublesome
and we are now working to
improve this kind of gap
so that we can actually
generate the robots
that can, at least 95%,
replicate the functionality
that can be achieved in a simulator.
Now we are seeing here is a robot
that a DiffuseBot
designed to do locomotion,
DiffuseBot automatically find
this kind of four leg creatures
that can try to walk forward,
it's kind of try to bend its leg
and then try to use the
frictions against the ground,
try to push forward its body.
When we're making a robot,
there's some imperfectness
during the fabrication,
such that there is some kind of asymmetry
between the two different robot body,
which makes it try to move
forward but also rotating
at the same times.
And we found that the
damping issue of the material
makes the robot cannot
achieve dynamic motion,
it's just moving forward
in the simulation.
- [Byungchul] When we changed the motor
to the high torque density motor
and if we think about the pushing force,
because this actuation is done
by tendon driven mechanism,
which can only generate the pulley pulls,
so maybe we can change the
locomotion after that one.
- [Johnson] The major issue
that we're solving now
in our ongoing project is try to make sure
the same to real gap is small enough
such that whatever we can
achieve in the simulation
can be replicated in the real world.